you  hey this chats done and I'm gonna go  make a shuttle stay here with me you're  right  yes simply go monitor if she that's the  new neighbor's house what the hell is on  you kid from across the street his name  is Robbie yeah his mama in the hospital  so he's just gonna stay there's no  relatives I don't know I've never met  his mom front door Oh mom I don't think  it was an accident it's really weird you  guys want to see something really cool  with the Kinect that you can do connect  projects tracking does whoa what's he  doing it's 3:00 in the morning  Robbie can you tell me who you're  talking to nobody  look at that what is that looks like a  triangle with a circle like a that's it  what does it mean he does not die what  who doesn't like me you'll find out  what you need to tell me what's going on  I don't want you to get hurt  you